i
présentera Dune vendredi.
Voici le compte rendu.
- Les vedettes débarquent enfin
à la Mostra de Venise, et malgré
la pandénie à l'arrière plan,
le festival veut en mettre plein
la vue avec entre autres
la première mondiale du film
"Dune" de Denis Villeneuve.
DENIS VILLENEUVE,
Réalisateur du film "Dune"
- Ça signifie une victoire.
C'est une victoire sur le fait
que enfin, le film va apparaître
sur grand écran.
- Les projecteurs ont été
braqués sur le réalisateur Pedro
Almodovar et son film "Madres
Paralelas", mettant en vedette
l'actrice Penelope Cruz
lors de la journée d'ouverture.
Demain,  on pourra voir
"Le pouvoir du chien", réalisé
par Jane Campion, et co-produit
par le québécois Roger Frappier.
- Faites décoller tous nos
appareils armés! En avant!
- Dans la catégorie hors-
compétition, le film "Dune"
de Denis Villeneuve sera
présenté en grande première
mondiale vendredi. Ce sera
la troisième fois que le
réalisateur québécois se rend
à la Mostra, un festival qui lui
a porté chance en 2011 pour son
film "Incendies", puis en 2016
pour son film "Arrival"
- C'est un festival où j'ai été
extrêmement bien accueilli
et qui sied parfaitement
dans le calendrier. Ça arrive
parfaitement au bon moment,
c'est un parfait timing
pour nous.
- Un autre Québécois,
le réalisateur Éric Gravel,
installé à Paris depuis 20 ans,
présentera son long-métrage
vendredi.
- Il y a des cars de
substitution pour la ligne P?
ÉRIC GRAVEL, réalisateur
du film "À plein temps"
- De voir qu'un grand festival
a un intérêt pour son film,
bien, c'est effectivement un
rêve qui se réalise. En tout
cas, c'est une magnifique façon
de présenter son film.
- La 78e édition de la Mostra
sera un grand cru, à la grand
surprise des organisateurs
du festival.
ALBERTO BARBERA, directeur
artistique du Festival
international du film de Venise
- La surprise la plus
intéressante, la plus grande,
c'est la qualité des films.
Jamais été aussi haute
en pourcentage. J'ai eu
l'impression que tout le monde
voulait recommencer, sortir
de chez eux, voyager,
montrer les films.
- Au delà de la fête,
le festival international
du film de Venise a lieu sous
haute surveillance sanitaire.
l'accès au tapis rouge
est limité, pas de caméra
aux conférences de presse,
et certains invités doivent
subir un test de dépistage
tous les jours.
- Nous, on se fait tester tous
les jours. Si j'étais positif,
ce matin je pourrais pas être
ici avec vous.
Moi, depuis le début de la
pandémie, mes pensées vont aux
gens qui travailllent dans les
hôpitaux, les gens du front qui
font en sorte que notre société
puisse fonctionner, qui
reçoivent tous ces gens.
Moi, c'est plus que je pense
qu'à ma première de film quand
il est le temps de penser
à la COVID. Sincèrement.
- En attendant un retour
à la normal, l'industrie
cinématographique s'affiche
comme elle peut et elle anticipe
des jours meilleurs.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Venise.